- When a great story catches
my eye on the internet,
I like to serve it up here.
This is what I'm liking.
A New Hampshire woman had
every reason to freak out
when she awoke to an intruder
in her house, as you would,
but it wasn't a burglar, it was a bear.
Which is scarier. I think maybe.
Just checking these photos out.
The furry guest trashed
the front of the house,
ripping out the walls
and eating insulation.
The woman's husband
managed to get the bear out
without incident,
but not before it left
thousands of dollars in damages.
We have that woman on the line right now.
So everybody say hi to Melissa
who watches on NBC Boston.
What's up Melissa?
- Hi Kelly.
- I mean, so is this like a normal thing
in your neighborhood?
Like bears in houses?
- No.
- Okay.
- The bears are outside,
yes, that's a normal thing,
but bears in the house? Not so much.
- Yeah. I'm like that's a big
old bear. He found the honey.
So wait, what did you guys do?
- First off we called the police
who called the game warden
who kind of said, well, it's gonna take,
we live in the middle of nowhere,
and it was gonna take him
quite some time to get to us.
And he says, well, I'll
gear up and head your way.
He wasn't at all happy about it.
And he says, I'm gonna call
you before I leave my driveway
and we'll see where we're at.
And in the meantime, my husband
did not wait with the bear
'cause it was just getting worse,
and there was the potential
that he could have come
through the dining room window
actually into the house.
So we were just trying to
figure out ways to get him out.
And I said, well just jump out the window
and open the door for him.
And he's like, Melissa, it's
eight feet off the ground,
I'm not jumping out the window.
And then so, but we remembered
there's a ladder on the roof
'cause we had been doing the chimney work.
So he decided that he would
go upstairs to the bedroom
and climb out that window
and open the door for him.
And he did, he was able to open the door,
and finally he left.
And what surprised me the most
about him leaving was that
he could have gone left or right
and kind of darted off into the woods,
but he walked up the
stairs to our driveway.
You have to go up a few stairs
to get to the top of our driveway.
He walked up the stairs as
though he'd been there before,
he knew that yard, he knew those stairs.
So I don't think this was his first visit,
just the first time he
got trapped in the house.
- Well, my personal
favorite part of the story
is when you thought your
husband was some kind of ninja
that was gonna jump out
an eight foot window.
That's my favorite part.
You were just like jump out
the window and handle it, son.
- If I could hold the door and
keep a 400 pound bear back,
he should have been able
to jump out the window.
- I love you. Thank you so much,
I'm so happy that y'all
are both all right.
This is a very funny story
because nothing bad happened,
but, and not funny, 'cause it
probably was very expensive
but I'm liking your post
right now. That's a big bear.
- [Melissa] Thank you so much.
- Well thank you so
much, and that's not all,
I want you to know our season long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of Frixion,
the go-to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show",
think that your experience is
just as wild as everyone does.
So they're gonna give you $1000.
Maybe that'll help with
some of the damage.
- Oh my goodness.
- [Kelly] All right,
thank you so much Melissa.
- [Melissa] Well thank you so much.